welcome back everybody to the david
pakman show luke beasley here filling in
for david today while he is away i don't
waste any time so let's just jump right
in donald trump spoke over the weekend
at the faith and freedom coalition event
in nashville tennessee this is one of
his first chances actually his first
chance in speech form at least to
address the bombshells that have been
revealed in the three january 6 hearings
that have happened so far and it was
also a chance for him to do you know
what he normally does in speeches which
is go through his greatest hits of
talking points and then kind of get on
random tangents about random things so
we're gonna be looking at some of the
moments from that speech today starting
with trump saying that no teacher should
be teaching students transgender
what that means i don't know not about
transgender people not any way you could
say that properly about
transgender singular let's take a look
pushing woke gender ideology
woke gender ideology
think of it on young people is nothing
less than child abuse
no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender to our children
without the parents consent and i don't
think too many people are going to be
giving that consent mark not too many
man we we got to keep those teachers
from teaching about transgender
wow of course he's playing into the
wright's favorite fear-mongering device
as of late which is the lgbtq community
doing everything they can to make their
followers distracted from anything
except being afraid of people who are
not like them
then trump moved on to speaking about
the public january 6 hearings and went
on this tangent about how great of a
nickname the unselect committee is what
he calls it it's the select committee
investigating january 6 but he calls it
the unselect committee and he was very
proud of coming up with this nickname
and i was actually watching his speech
on my own live stream which you can uh
subscribe to my channel at lukebeasley
on youtube if you're watching this on
youtube or listening to the podcast
there will be a link in the description
you just click it go to my channel
subscribe or if you listen to podcasts i
also put it out in audio form so you can
search my name on any podcast listening
platform but i was watching his speech
on a live stream and he got into this
tangent about ooh the unselect committee
isn't that such a great nickname and for
some reason it just tickled me so much
so i had to include it here's that
being staged by the unselect
committee i love that name unsolved you
know they never they actually act you
know they hate it right but they act
like there's nothing wrong because they
just don't want they're very good at
what they do
they're con people they're con artists
i say the unselected is supposed to be
the select committee on january you know
like these people are legitimate
the unselects so i call them the
unselects and they act like oh
they never mention that i think it's one
of the great they'd never mention it
someday they'll give me credit for that
term
i had a lot of good terms we had a lot
of good nicknames didn't we didn't we
have great victims
i think this is one of the best i don't
know it's not catching on because they
won't let it catch on
just
a genius of comedy and of burns man i
can't even can't even take it and then
he moved on to talking about how calm of
a speech january 6th was he said it
possibly was his calmest speech that
he's ever given wow
can you believe it
to various speeches including one i gave
remember the calm words i used they try
and make them sound like that was a com
that might have been the calmest speech
i think i've ever made if you want to
know
i've had a couple of senators say i
never knew you could be so nice
next he points out that for some reason
the january 6 hearings aren't focused
on the election lies that i've been
telling of course in his mind they're
not focusing on the massive fraud uh or
he called it the stuff we want to hear
they're not focusing on the stuff we
want to hear
let's go ahead and take a look at that
how crooked it was meanwhile the
committee refuses to play
any of the tape of people saying the
good things the things that we want to
hear
it's a one-way street
it's a rigged deal
can you imagine the january 6 hearing is
not spending time focusing on the lies
that caused the event
that the january 6th hearing is even
looking into
wild
finally he decides to go ahead and talk
about mike pence and in that he denies
that he called mike pence a wimp which
is one of the things that came out of
these hearings was people saying they
remembered him uh taking this really
harsh tone against mike pence and
calling him a wimp as well as other
things but apparently that didn't happen
according to trump
one guy got up and said that he
heard me calling mike pence away now
in honesty i'm the president of the
united states
you know i'm sitting i think they set up
my guest he's a wimp how many people
listen to me it's like i don't even know
who these people are
but i never called mike pence a wimp i
never called him a wimp mike pence
had a chance to be great
he had a chance to be frankly historic
but just like bill barr and the rest of
these weak people
mike and i say it sadly because i like
them
but mike did not have the courage
to act
so there we go uh nothing too surprising
from him in his response
going on with the same lies about the
2020 election pretending that pence
should have stepped in the way
of our constitutional process and
he's just further increasing the
likelihood that
they will
attempt to do this again and maybe it'll
be successful next time and that's what
really scares me all the evidence that
has come out during these hearings
hasn't made him stop for one moment to
think
maybe i should
go ahead and move on from this and
obviously i didn't think he was going to
come out and become this defender of
democracy and you know revoke all the
things he said before no but i at least
hoped it would be so embarrassing the
hard evidence that was presented in
these hearings which i think they've
done a good job of doing but i was
hoping that would at least get him to go
i'm gonna
back off of this a little bit even if
i'm not gonna ever
change what i believe or change what i
say publicly i'm just gonna stop talking
about it so much but no his only
response to all this is to keep telling
the lies that god got us into this mess
and that is
very very frightening
guys this this next story is is pitiful
ever since the evolity shooting there's
been a spike uh in the discussions
rightfully so about gun control and
that means many more republicans than
usual are going to have to be asked why
they stand in the way of any common
sense gun reform
and shockingly enough a host on fox news
actually asks senator mike lee a really
good question and she shows polling on
the support for a number of these big
main common-sense gun reforms that
people push for and shows just how
wildly popular they are and then asks
senator mike lee
aren't you out of step with your
constituents if
these
items these proposals are this popular
let's look at how he responds strength
behind some of these proposals
at this point some of these proposals
background checks for guns which by and
large most of them are uh background
checks before you do a purchase 88
percent though moving the legal age for
an assault rifle purchase is at 82
percent flagging for people uh who are
danger to themselves or others those red
flag laws 81 and banning assault weapons
63
um there is a lot of momentum at least
among the public sphere for doing this
are you out of step with your
constituents
okay so first of all what's important is
that we look out for the rights of
constituents constituents are asked poll
questions they're not asked questions
about specific language within
legislative texts it's the job of the
law maker to look out for the interest
and the rights of the law-abiding
citizens they represent
and so with each of those provisions i
understand how they could get high
popularity readings when they don't
define them for example you talk about
banning assault weapons there there is
no universal definition of what an
assault rifle is very often the true
distinction uh it really depends on
whether the stock pieces of the gun are
made of wood or of plastic or of
composite
um and and so
that the text does matter here
because it's that text that will
determine uh whether we're intruding
unduly on the rights of the americans
the american law-abiding citizen uh in
doing so in a way that would actually
deter violent criminal behavior
so first off even though this is not
something we should have to do
journalists should always be this way i
want to thank the fox news host for
actually asking a real question and i
just want to make sure you guys don't
get at all misled about this because i
think we have a tendency when someone's
on television and they
finish a complete sentence and then look
at the camera confidently we go oh dang
they successfully dodged the question
but no that entire clip he said a lot of
words
with zero substance
he goes on and on about the text of the
bill the text to the bill yes that's
your job you're a legislator
your job is to take general proposals
that are popular in the country and then
are popular among your constituents at
least
and then implement them and
throughout that process you work out the
specifics of the bill you work out the
details that you are referring to as the
text of the bill
we all recognize that universal
background checks is a little bit more
complicated than just writing down on a
bill universal background checks
go right we understand that you don't
need to say that to us
but you as sure as hell should not be
using it as an excuse for not acting on
the issue um there's a lot of specifics
that we don't know about yet well get
working buddy
his answer of course should have been
i absolutely support those proposals you
just put on screen as you mentioned they
are both popular and they would save
lives and they don't infringe on our
rights
all i want to do now is work on the nuts
and bolts of this legislation and then
we'll be able to accomplish the goals
set out by those more general positions
that you just outlined but instead he
gives the weakest and laziest
answer to get out of genuinely answering
why he doesn't support the reforms that
would save lives as i mentioned and
would be in line with his own
constituents
he didn't even answer her specific
question
really which was are you out of line
with your constituents yes is the answer
to that question he said effectively oh
well the reason is his constituents
aren't able to look out for their own
rights
that's his job well no your constituents
understand by that polling that
it's not an infringement on their right
to regulate uh firearms in a common
sense way
and i honestly don't know how people
like mike lee feel good about themselves
after giving an answer that's that slimy
and that dishonest
you gave that answer to protect the gun
lobby and this delusional idea that any
form of regulation
and trying to implement any common sense
gun reform
is revoking the second amendment or
something
and i know this sometimes comes off as a
little bit hyperbolic but honestly how
do people like mike lee live with
themselves knowing all of these
tragedies are going to happen in the
future or
not all of them but a number of
tragedies are going to happen in the
future because we didn't act now
and he's one of the people standing in
the way giving dishonest answers like
that
to
for really no good reason and it's going
to cause these tragedies and i really
don't know how people like him
live with will live with themselves
i'm sure you are all very familiar at
this point with herschel walker who is
running for senate in
georgia against raphael warnock and
recently there was a sort of scandal
where he made a remark
about how this is the context this isn't
the scandal but he made a remark about
how
a problem in the black community is
fathers aren't staying with their kids
and they absolutely absolutely need to
do that and it's a really big problem
and i mean we can have a discussion of
course we want to encourage people to
stay with their kids absolutely that's
not not really what this is about
it's more a hypocrisy angle and so just
to refresh your memory let's look at a
couple of those moments
the fatherless home is a major major
problem even if you have to leave that
woman even if you have to leave that
woman you don't leave the child right
right you let that child know you try to
work it out you're going to be
respectful to her if you're going to be
respectable to other things you show
that to your child marshall walker who
was born in wrightsville georgia you
know i took it i took care of a lot of
people in my hometown i took care of a
lot of the places around where i grew up
i was being like a father to some of
those kids that it may have had fun so
generally i have no problem as i said
with people encouraging you know men to
stay in their families and all those
things of course that's absolutely what
fathers should do but one of the ways
the republicans
specifically get out of
answering for any real policy
prescriptions they have for the country
in regard to these really big problems
sometimes that are more specific to
certain communities
is by making it an individual issue and
so instead of proposing large actions
that the government could take or
actions that we should as a political
body uh invest in time or energy
money
instead
it's all about that guy that one and
that one and that one on that one
it's just they made bad decisions which
on an individual basis if that person
was my friend yeah i'd give them that
advice hey stay with your kids right
but on a societal basis these big
problems that he's trying to address
in answering whatever question he was
answering is
something we have to address on a
societal basis basis big trends
big issues that we see
broadly
in our country
aren't going to be
solved by someone just saying a bunch of
rhetoric
and people are gonna hear stay with your
kids and now all of a sudden all these
problems are gonna be solved no if you
see broad
societal problems we're gonna have to
have broad societal solutions and those
have to be policies
that we can implement
using our political power and so
republicans do a really good job of
getting out of answering for hey what's
some policies that you that you would
propose to invest in these communities
uplift them instead they make it
it's just some bad dudes that's the core
of all these problems but you and i
understand
uh specifically since he was referring
to them the black community
the way that we solve any problems that
we recognize are
unique to that community is not just by
finger wagging right again you have a
friend you want to give them that advice
awesome or even you want to encourage
society broadly stay with your kids love
your kids of course you should do that
but that's not the solution to all these
problems we have that we need
to
[Music]
uh we need to address
and to put a cherry on top of all of it
herschel walker's son
is very outspoken he's a conservative
and he put out a video supporting his
dad's message that was a little bit
cringey
fathers it would be great if you stayed
home and raised your kids instead of ran
off to bang a bunch of women who weren't
your baby mama stay home and raise your
freaking kids your kids need a father
get back home get back home if you take
out your thing and you get a woman
pregnant guess what the party days are
over the acting foolish days are over
you go get a freaking job and you
support your new
family get home raise your so very
in your face so that's kind of all the
context to the story that we're talking
about today
that would mean a lot maybe more at
least coming from someone who's living
the principles that they're espousing
who is loving and supporting their kids
all of their kids
but after these statements made by
herschel walker it came out that he had
three children with three separate women
who were not previously disclosed to the
public which for someone as famous as
him to have kept them unknown for that
long
that's not an accident and there is no
way he was active in their lives in the
way that he's saying other people should
be
uh or there would be some public record
of that some
public record for someone as famous as
him
so you would think that would upset that
type of hypocrisy that type of not
living your family values would upset
evangelical people right that's what
they they claim to care about
uh no
i'm sure you'll guess that
hershel walker received resounding
applause from evangelical christian
activists on saturday following
revelations he had fathered three
children he had not previously discussed
publicly the half full room of
conference goers at the faith and
freedom coalition's annual gathering in
nashville went wild for walker perhaps
the most high-profile republican senate
candidate this cycle running in one of
the most contested
races
even though it is really clear by now
that republicans don't really care about
having politicians who live the
principles they claim to hold it still
fascinates me every single time when
this you know plain examples of
hypocrisy come out and they don't care
at all a very clear example of this is
trump
evangelical evangelical republicans
claimed to care about family values and
that's what justified them being super
judgmental towards all of these groups
who didn't live the way that they wanted
them to live
i.e the lgbtq community but then trump
comes along
has a very anti-evangelical past if you
want to say it that way and
they don't care at all it's wild
um and i think this is honestly one of
the reasons that they are still as
successful as they are because they'll
take anybody as long as you'll say their
talking points spread their message act
the way that they want you to act you're
in
it's not about consistency it's not
authenticity it's power if you can take
power and use it towards their ends the
ins they actually care about then
you're a part of the club and the funny
thing is comparing that to the left is
pitiful because the left if you step on
a bug
you're out so we could take a little bit
of a lesson from them and be a little
bit more tolerant of people with
not perfect pasts but generally i like
where we stand i'll be following
herschel walker's
race with raphael warnock that has been
very fascinating so far but i'll be
watching it each step of the way and
covering it on my own show you can find
that at luke beasley on youtube or if
you're listening to this as a podcast
you can search luke easley on any
podcast listening platform to listen to
it we'll be back with much more
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
welcome back everybody to the david
pakman show luke beasley here filling in
for david while he is away don't forget
to check out my youtube luke beasley on
youtube or luke beasley on any podcast
listening platform if you are a listener
there was a texas gop convention over
the weekend where a number of notable
things happened one of the big takeaways
from a couple of these moments is that
the far right
isn't
far right enough for the extreme
you know radical right wingers that are
becoming more prominent so what i'm
talking about is dan crenshaw was
walking through an event and got
aggressively accosted by some right
wingers not liberals
the left's not going after him it's
these far far right people
going after dan crenshaw
calling him a rhino republican in name
only let's take a look at this video and
then we'll discuss
i patch mccain hey i patch mckay look at
i passed mccain right here you're rhino
you're globalist you're globalist right
now
[Music]
and red flag laws too dan that's
ridiculous
hey dan why are you on the world
economic forum young global leaders
world economic forum young global leader
hey dan what's claus schwab's number you
got clash royale's number
one so they're screaming at him calling
him a globalist rhino again that's
republican and name only and usually
people call
uh
other republicans rhinos if they're not
pro-trump enough or far-right
enough and then they also were calling
him eye patch mccain which is a
term tucker carlson coined which is
bizarre why i never understand stop
going after people's physical features
just go after their positions their
policies that's it it's crazy or there
you know lack of principles whatever it
is anything that's not physical
appearance related or the fact that he's
you know has
damage to one of his eyes
um
you could see it seem to escalate to
actual violence
i couldn't quite tell with that video
what
happened but from the reporting as well
as what you could hear in the video it
looked like something really got
physical besides just them kind of
pressing up
and then i guess one of the guys was
very upset that dan crenshaw is involved
in the world economic forum which i know
very little about but klaus schwab he
kept saying is the founder of it
um
i don't know what his deal is with all
of that but
the crazy thing is dan crenshaw is very
pro-trump and he's very conservative but
he just barely sort of critiqued trump
and wasn't the most you know outspoken
the election was stolen person he kind
of avoided that question
and then he supports red flag laws was
one of the things they brought up
and that's what you're angry about that
tiny little difference between trump and
him and between you and him he's a
conservative guy and they're still not
happy with them it's crazy because their
actual policy differences are so tiny
it just they you know dan crenshaw
doesn't appear radical enough for their
liking
because if you think about democrats
aoc and joe manchin the difference
between the difference between those two
people is
way larger than any republicans
um in their policy differences and yet
leftists aren't going out and accosting
joe manchin
like that
in the spirit of this at the same texas
event ted cruz got made fun of uh for
being a trump bootlicker but
in a contradictory way you know he first
criticized trump a lot on the campaign
trail and trump alluded to his wife
being ugly and his dad may have caused
you know done 9 11.
like ted cruz like you don't talk about
my family like that
um so against you and then trump wins
the nomination and ted cruz
so a guy walked up he's not the hero
but he makes correct points let's take a
look america you know that remember how
trump made fun of your wife and then you
go become best friends and trust you i
know but why do you do that you go
become best friends with trump after he
makes fun of you and your wife why do
you do that i understand you don't want
it
see you don't you care more about the
border between uh ukraine and russia
than you care about the border between
texas and mexico why is that
why do you care about god bless you i
know but why are you globalist you're a
globalist but you know it ted hey
you're a globalist ted you know that bud
and that's why you're a coward and a
liar and you know that and i know that
and that's why you're afraid to stand up
for when people were freezing and dying
you were in cancun mexico you remember
that you remember when you're at the
all-inclusive buffet why people were
freezing
no but do you remember that ted when
everybody was freezing remember that
when people were dying
so like i said
that guy's law office rocker if you ever
hear someone use the term globalist
or as david pakman says
impersonating alex jones globalish
most the time i guess you could use that
term if you meant like someone who's
pro-globalization a globalist or like
pro
there could be an okay usage of that
word definitionally but the way that
it's used in politics is almost always
super conspiratorial and an indication
that someone's a little but the points
he was making besides that weren't wrong
right i mean
it can be forgotten that ted cruz kissed
up to donald trump after
trump alluded to his wife being ugly
oh maybe his dad did 9 11 is what trump
was uh spouting off about and ted was so
brave at that point characterizing trump
is such a terrible candidate
and then trump won the nomination and
ted cruz is the biggest bootlicker
and then also it shouldn't be forgotten
as that guy pointed out that texas was
in that big freeze and texans are or
were suffering and he flew off the
cancun and then blamed it on his
daughters that was so
so weird this is a complete side note
but during that freeze because it's
popped up this is a crazy cute story
at that point my family we were all here
and we had
12 puppies
not my entire family wasn't here but i
was here sister parents and we had 12
puppies golden retriever puppies
from a golden retriever that we had and
or we still have and these 12 puppies
were at like
little
weeks old and so whenever the freeze
happened all the power went out and
if they stayed out in our house when it
got that cold they would all have died
luckily we had one little space heater
so we packed in this tiny little room
used the space heater to keep the
puppies alive it was wild and during all
of that instead of ted cruz coming and
helping us with our puppies no he could
have helped other people um he was off
in cancun living up
the good life
so
he's a goofball the guy who walked up to
ted cruz but so is ted cruz so he kind
of deserves it and the points he was
making uh were definitely correct and i
love how ted cruz's reaction is always
just completely not address what they're
saying he was he kept saying like oh i
know you you don't love texas or you
don't want to defend texas okay yeah
sure ted
so we discussed dan crenshaw getting
harassed ted cruz getting confronted by
far right wingers at this event
in texas the gop convention
in texas that occurred over the weekend
well at the same convention
these texas republicans voted to
officially declare
the 2020 election of joe biden
illegitimate meeting at their first
in-person convention since 2018 texas
republicans on saturday acted on a raft
of resolutions and proposed platform
changes to move the party even further
to the right they approved measures
declaring the president that president
joe biden was not legitimately elected
and rebuking senator john cornyn for
taking part in bipartisan gun talks they
also voted on a platform that declares
homosexuality an abnormal lifestyle
choice and calls for texas school
children to learn about the humanity of
the pre-born child
so the second largest republican party
in the country second only to the
national republican party is coming out
and saying
that the election was stolen they're
proclaiming it
the election in 2020
was stolen and this is incredibly
damaging
and frightening
um and this is why before i say this
though
i have some conservatives in my audience
who say that they watch my show they
don't agree with me i'm on pretty much
anything but they feel like i'm level
headed so they can stand to watch it
they get a sense of what the left
believes but then i've had a couple of
them reach out and say except
you're hyperbolic on the trump january
6th you know election being overturned
um
stuff and so whenever i hear criticisms
i always want to see if i can soak it in
and see if there's any truth to it and
see if i should change my own behaviors
but no this is a great example
this is as bad as i'm describing it
our democracy is being actively
undermined by a major political figure
and a major political party
if they get in power and something like
this happens again we know that our
democracy may not survive
because all the things that trump tried
to do
leading up to january 6 and even beyond
and is still spouting off about now
if he was able to do this successfully
we would not have a democracy because a
individual an individual who did not win
an election would have stayed in power
and that is not how a democracy
functions and so no i'm not being
hyperbolic on this i promise you even if
you're conservative really look at the
facts of the situation
we have a massive threat to our
democracy and it comes in the form of
trump and the movement that he leads
and it's shameful that
they don't all see
that there's this active effort to chip
away aggressively at the stability and
strength of our democracy it's wild and
maybe they do see it this would be worse
and they just don't care they might see
it
and not care
we've been doing a lot of coverage of
this texas gop convention that occurred
over the weekend
just coincidentally a lot of wild stuff
happened at it and one of those things
was the organization of gay republicans
called the log cabin republicans got
banned
from having a booth at the convention so
they were no longer allowed to show up
at uh as an organization obviously i'm
sure individuals could have still gone
but because they represented a gay
representation organization they were
not allowed to set up their normal booth
a group of texas republicans who
represent conservatives in the lgbtq
community said they were denied the
ability to set up a booth at the texas
republican party convention the log
cabin republicans at fort worth a
chapter of the national log cabin
republicans organization said they were
not allowed to set up a booth at the
convention which took place in houston
over the weekend and featured several
republican organizations and vendors the
fort worth star telegram reported the
move prompted a comment from the
national log cabin republicans whose
president called the decision narrow
minded it's clear that inclusion wins
which makes the texas republican party
leadership's decision to exclude the
texas law cap and republicans from the
convention not just narrow-minded but
politically short-sighted uh president
charles moran said in a statement citing
former president donald trump's support
of the lgbtq republicans so that charles
his name is m-o-r-a-n
just i just want to say [ __ ] [ __ ]
is correct that this is narrow-minded
and short-sighted by the republican
party
but it bothers me because even though in
this situation i don't at all think that
his organization should have been banned
from participating in that event
he should have known that that's the
party he's been supporting for all these
years he and his organization do this
shameful thing where they give
legitimacy to the outrageous claims that
the right makes about the lgbtq
community by you know they bolster it
by
also reciprocating those claims but i'm
an lgbtq person so i can get away with
it is what they
do and it's like you should have known
that the party you're standing behind
the party that you advocate on behalf of
does not stand for a world where you are
included
and you should have expected this to
happen eventually you spew these lies
and hate about the community that you're
a part of
eventually they're going to come for you
too and it's just super fascinating i
guess to give some leeway to the
organization because gay marriage um
was legalized there was this little
moment if you all remember where it
seemed like
maybe the republican party was gonna
talk less about
the lgbtq type stuff
and pretend to be a little bit inclusive
if you remember trump literally said
multiple times that he was
a pro-gay president or whatever uh maybe
not pro-gay but an ally of the community
but then somewhat recently
they just turned the dial back to 11 and
are focusing all of their hatred on
lgbtq americans so while the party
shouldn't exclude this group of course
from being a part of their conventions a
part of their party the log cabin
republicans shouldn't have been
supporting this party for all of these
years and this is
the chickens coming home to roost
unfortunately you can't join a party
that is actively working to erase your
existence and then claiming your
existence is bad and wrong and then
making your existence the center point
of their hateful platform
and then be surprised whenever they
turn their backs on you
if you want to hear more of what i have
to say on issues like this don't forget
to go subscribe to my youtube channel
where i drop
videos daily you can find that by going
to luke beasley on youtube or if you're
watching this on youtube or listening to
the podcast there will be a link in the
description you can click and it'll take
you to my channel you can also listen to
my show as a podcast on any podcast
listening platform
we'll be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow welcome back everybody
to the david pakman show luke beasley
here filling in for david today while he
is away taking care of his new baby
if you like what you see here definitely
go subscribe to my youtube channel by
searching luke beasley on youtube if you
want to get the video form or luke
beasley on any podcast listening
platform if you just want to listen
father's day was over the weekend as i'm
sure you're aware and a lot of people
spend father's day doing different
things but
things like spending time with family or
if you're a father maybe
you have your family surround you and
give you appreciation
go out barbecuing whatever you do
something fun like that but not
not if you're the former president
donald trump trump spent father's day
angrily sending out messages on his
social media site truth social just
absolutely losing it so here's the first
sweet father's day message
from donald j trump
the highly partisan unselects are trying
to create i'm not gonna do that the
whole time are trying to create a fake
narrative for whatever reason but only
with evil intention that he
knew the election was stolen this is
completely false i felt the election was
rigged and stolen i have from the very
beginning and i have only gotten
stronger in that belief with time
and large amounts of additional evidence
and proof in my mind i have and have had
no question and many people will be
willing to attest
big bold all caps all throughout that
but the unslecks don't want to hear
them
okay well he started off strong father's
day but then
then he cools off maybe no what let's
see you ready for this
witch hunt that was his next message all
caps witch hunt that's it
it's too much former president
surely now he's gonna wrap it up
enjoy his father's day spend some time
eating a big mac with ivanka no
i am leading in every poll by a lot and
the democrats are doing everything they
can to change that even if it's another
russia russia russia hoax mueller scam
impeachment waste of time or whatever
the same lying people saying the same
kind of thing i only want to and then in
all caps make america great again
so to the polling thing he is doing a
lot better in polling than he probably
should be that's crazy uh of the last
four he's beating biden in two so
biden's winning in two he's winning in
two
not completely accurate what he said but
it's still there's some truth to it that
he is leading in recent polls that's
frightening
and next he addresses the georgia phone
call that happened of course where he
asked the secretary of state to find him
11 000 whatever votes
that would help him flip the election
to being a win for him my phone call to
the georgia secretary of state with many
other people including numerous lawyers
knowing knowingly on the line was
absolutely perfect and appropriate yes
it was a perfect call and so was the
second call for which the washington
post was forced to do a major and
somewhat embarrassing retraction thank
you
okay so the georgia call was fine even
though i was trying to pressure a
secretary of state to find 11 000
something votes that would help me win
the election even though i didn't
perfect phone call well finally to wrap
it up i have to be fair
he did say at the very end i want to
wish everyone a beautiful father's day
filled with peace
love
and compassion no he didn't say that at
all um i have so many witnesses to
everything good that that sentence is so
weird i have so many witnesses to
everything good
but the highly partisan and one-sided
unselect committee of political hacks
has not
interest in hearing has not interest in
hearing or seeing them
this witch hunt could all be ended
quickly if they did
so a little bit of a typo there
not interest they have not interest
very fascinating um
but instead of hanging out with his
children where they can say you're a
great father they can lie and tell them
that
eric
don ivanka no instead he's maybe he was
with them i don't know but not spending
quality time because instead he was
ranting and raving
about
all of those things
what we're going to be looking at is
super concerning there's a gop candidate
for senate in missouri
eric greitens who put out a campaign ad
and the whole ad
is him and a few other guys
going
rhino hunting which republican in name
only rhino hunting
now instead of
describing first how scary and all this
type of stuff this is let's just go
ahead and take a look at the video
greitens navy seal and today we're going
rhino hunting
the rhino feeds on corruption and is
marked by the stripes of cowardice
join the maggot crew get a rhino hunting
permit there's no bagging limit no
tagging limit and it doesn't expire
until we save our country
so i know at this point you've probably
seen a lot of campaign ads particularly
from republicans that are promoting some
level of violence
but you can't allow yourself to get
numbed out
to this type of
terrible material he releases an ad
where his entire premise
is around killing other republicans
rhinos republicans name only
for what not being loyal enough to trump
which is usually their issue with people
is they're not loyal enough not a big
enough trump bootlicker
and there's not even a metaphor there
i mean it's not like a a thinly veiled
threat of violence no he's just saying
you all know rhinos we say republicans a
name only
yeah let's go hunt them let's go kill
them
that's the campaign now that's it
and literally we're at the point where a
candidate can for the united states
senate put out a campaign ad that they
think is going to help their chances in
the campaign or they want to have put it
out and say hey everyone all my
followers let's go hunt people let's go
hunt politicians
this is
so normal now somehow i mean we're
covering it so it's not that normal it's
still crazy
but it's way more normal than it should
be and we've seen a number of republican
ads that are candidates holding a gun
and talking about fighting the
opposition
and
all these other insinuations of violence
but this is an escalation of violence
that i'm so afraid of
this type of content that we're seeing
become real common
is
it's not funny and it's not something
that should be overlooked because
as this type of rhetoric escalates the
likelihood that real world violence will
be
inflicted
becomes much more likely and that's
something that i'm
super super afraid of for our country
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
luke beasley here filling in for david
while he's away on paternity leave we
have a fascinating story to talk about
so as has been widely covered over the
last few years amazon's work environment
is pretty horrible and there's been a
lot of stories revealed about people not
being able to go to the restroom
properly like they're driving down the
road and they have so little time that
they're expected to do something that
they're
going to the restroom you know in their
car in a bag or something um being
expected to do way too much and not
being treated correctly
for it and one of the reasons that this
work environment was the way that it was
was actually sort of intentional
amazon higher ups had designed it where
you get pushed so hard
that there's no way you're gonna stay
very long and they're okay with that
they're gonna have a really high
turnover rate but then while you're
there extract as much work as possible
and not treat you the way that you
should be treated so they go through a
massive amount of employees
each month and each year who just go in
they go out they go in they go out and
they grind them down so aggressively and
so quickly so besides public pressure it
was actually working for the higher-ups
you know if you think from their
perspective that we're getting a lot of
work out of these people
and
making huge
profits until now and this is wild
reading from yahoo finance amazon's no
frill low wage high turnover labor model
is beginning to show signs of stress the
tech giant could run out of workers to
hire for its warehouses by 2024
according to a leaked amazon internal
research memo
from mid-2021 seen by the publication
recode
putting its service quality growth plans
and quick labor churn model in a pinch
if we continue business as usual amazon
will deplete the available labor supply
in the u.s network by 2024 the leaked
report indicated so because they push
their workers so hard they're literally
going to be in a situation where at all
these given warehouses
all the vicinity around where they can
hire from aren't going to have enough
employees potential employees who are
within the you know type of employee
that would work that particular position
who haven't already left amazon is that
insane
so what is their solution well reading
again from yahoo finance the memo said
amazon had six levers it could use to
delay the labor crisis by a few years
including raising wages and increasing
automation but the only way to
significantly alter this timeline is to
make sweeping changes to the way it
manages its employees so
obviously
automation could possibly help them with
this take away some of the jobs that
they need but it's not going to do it
all and so i love how they stumbled into
what we've been all screaming at them
for a long time now you're one of the
biggest corporations in the world you
make tons of money you can afford to pay
your workers correctly and treat them
correctly
and it's crazy because they are just now
realizing hey if we want people to work
here do we have to not abuse them do we
have to be decent to them is that
something that we have to do
yes unbelievable um well i hope that
they go in this direction of course and
treat all their workers the way that
they deserve to be treated um wish they
could have figured this out earlier but
we'll take it now
three of the big
public january 6 select committee
hearings have occurred and one of the
big questions people are asking amidst
all of this is
is there any chance trump will be held
legally responsible for the actions he
took namely his attempt to overturn a
free and fair election and keep himself
in power i covered the story that we're
about to talk about on my own show
you can find it by just searching luke
beasley on youtube or if you're watching
this on youtube or listening to the
podcast it will be in the description so
you can just click the link it will take
you there
or you can just like i said search my
name luke b is on youtube and then david
likely also covered this when it came
out but i thought it'd be really
interesting to look at in the context of
these hearings and all the revelations
that have come out to take an another
look at this so quote a former federal
prosecutor who served for more than 24
years in the district of columbia's u.s
attorney's office says donald trump
could be arrested or indicted on just
the evidence included in monday's
bombshell legal ruling by u.s district
court judge david o'carter so now
describes that legal ruling judge
carter's findings by a preponderance of
the evidence which says more likely than
not that trump committed felony offenses
is a higher evidence jury standard than
the one needed to arrest and indict
trump for his crimes which requires only
probable cause
judge carter on monday wrote based on
the evidence the court finds it's more
likely than not that president trump
corruptly attempted to obstruct the
joint session of congress on january 6
2021. in response legal experts are
calling his ruling striking massive
monumental and historic so this was a
ruling about john eastman whether or not
he had to
turn over documents to the january 6th
committee but as you saw in there this
judge is saying it's likely there's
enough evidence to indict trump on
criminal charges that's insane
but obviously the big question is is it
likely
okay we can talk about wow he should be
but is this actually something's gonna
happen
and at this point i think david pakman's
assessment
um that we probably shouldn't be
expecting to see trump do the perp walk
is still correct unfortunately in the
country we live in
powerful people are rarely held
accountable to this extent and actually
there's some other reasons for why
merrick garland might be timid and there
are legitimate reasons i don't think
they're enough for him not to go through
with it but i read this op-ed by the new
york times that made a case for why it
wouldn't be so crazy for merrick garland
to um
be really you know
soft
and uh timid on this particular issue
and
while i think it's it's it's wrong in
its assessment like
regardless of the backlash regardless of
the
um political claims that will be made
we should follow rule of law if trump
committed crimes he needs to be held
criminally responsible but i do
understand how scary and wild it is to
think about the aftermath of something
like this if trump was indicted
the riots the insane mayhem that would
happen i mean that is something to be
feared for sure um
but that can't scare us away from doing
what is right which is holding trump
accountable if he committed crimes of
course i'm not a legal expert
i would want the legal experts of course
to
analyze and see not just what trump did
but compared to the law
how did he clearly break it and if he
did he needs to be held responsible
it's also really horrible to think about
the potential where um
the potential world where trump is
unsuccessfully
prosecuted and for the rest of time he's
just so bolstered in his claims that
this is also political and he's been
correct the whole time that this was all
witch hunt don't like thinking about
that hypothetical so i think behind the
scenes merrick garland needs to make a
really strong case or see if he can make
based on the evidence a really strong
case and if you can't don't pursue it
but if there is a clear
laws he violated
actions he took
evidence to prove it then he needs to go
through with it maybe he you know
appoints a special prosecutor to do that
process
but
beforehand he needs to see if there's
such clear hard evidence that this would
be an undeniable case to prove
and you honestly wish that we would be
in a country where people could look at
this evidence and look
at the actions that trump took and
changed their mind
you know like all of these people on the
right
i wish they would just watch the january
6 hearings with an open mind and not
think this is all fake news
because a lot of this is so clear what
trump did and if they believed he did
what he did you would hope they would no
longer want to support him i don't know
maybe they're also just not for
democracy but hopefully you believe the
only reason that they support this
anti-democratic behavior is because they
think it's saving the democracy because
it was stolen from trump right just to
kind of close it is interesting a
majority of americans do support
indicting trump actually but it's
54 so it's not like the whole country or
anything the survey found that 54 of
respondents backed the idea of the
department of justice indicting the
former president over the capital riot
compared to 37 percent who oppose the
suggestion
obviously and i'll say this many times
it needs to come down to the evidence
can the doj make an undeniable case that
trump violated certain laws here they
are and here's the evidence of those
violations and if they can then he
should absolutely be prosecuted
let me know in the comments what you
guys think i'm super curious to hear
likely unlikely give me your assessment
definitely in the comments thank you so
much to the dave hackman show for having
me guest host today
you can check out my channel if you're
watching on youtube or listening the
podcast just by going to the description
and click clicking the link it'll take
you to my channel or if you're coming
from another place just search luke
beasley on youtube or luke beasley on
any podcast listening platform and you
should be able to find my show
be well everybody